hello everyone if you ask a hundred
different people who was the greatest
pirate ever you will get a lot of
different answers but if you ask a
hundred chess players who was the
greatest pirate ever I believe the
answer will be unanimous as eighty-one
years ago on this day in 1936 one of the
well not one of the greatest pirate ever
was born in Riga Latvia mechanic mah
tall and well as chess world has seen
its fair share of pirates but only one
pirate man and managed pillage his way
all the way to the world champion
championship title and well he did the
graces with with tons of amazing games I
mean games like these is exactly the
reason why I never include Tallinn my
sorcery series as pretty much every tile
game is a is a pure sorcery so
definitely quite a guy and as you all
know well not all of you but many of you
know he's my favorite player and
definitely we should we should do a nice
game or two for his birthday this would
be his 81st birthday if he was still
alive but unfortunately as tall was the
magician on the board he also the way he
played it was also the way he lived he
enjoyed a lot of alcohol a lot of
cigarettes a lot of women and while this
led to his early downfall at the age of
55 I believe the the official medical
report was that he died of a hemorrhage
in the esophagus in 1992 some one month
after that that win against the Gary
Kasparov in that blitz tournament I also
had that game on my channel so that
you're free to check it out if you'd
like this game here it was played in
1956 Michael Tao with the black pieces
is playing against young Luke star and I
don't have the slightest idea if I
pronounce that name right he's a Polish
chess player in 1953 some three years
ago before this game he won the the
Polish Junior champ
chip and he represented Poland in a lot
of international matches but to this
game he plays against the pirate of Riga
so let's see how it went and for those
of you who enjoy the Kings Indian this
game will be quite a treat so we have d4
and Knight to f6 c4g six nights the c3
Bishop to g7 C for D 6 f3 the semi
variation of the Kings Indian tell
castles Bishop to e3
now e5 Knight the g2e to c6 and Queen to
b3 all standard theory moves for King's
Indian and there are a lot of options
for black here one might enjoy Knight B
to d7 a6 is an option but tal sees the
white king still in the center still
sitting there on a one and he
immediately wants to open up the center
he captures on d4 Knight captures on d4
and already on mu9 a very interesting
decision by the pirate of riga d5 upon
sacrifice purely because the king is
still anyone no reason not to do it
c captures on d5 we have seek after
sandy v and here the Polish chess player
accepts the challenge he captures on d5
and always I mean your king is on e1
that's too deadly are there to give a
guy like tau playing a move like rook to
e8 here would definitely give tall the
advantage pinning the bishop on e3 but
rook to e8 is is a great move but it's
not a pirate move a pirate move is what
style plate and top plate Knight to c6
and what is this I mean this is this
move is so terrible that it's basically
just giving white a piece so naturally
white accepts this D captures on c6 and
here we have the immediate rook to e8 so
like I said rook to e8 the previous move
would clearly give a tally advantage but
tal first gave up a piece and only then
he plays rook to e8 and now giving white
a lot of options and this is something
that tal was famous for so white has to
consider
a lot of things does he capture see
captures mv7 does he capture the knight
on d4 since the bishop is pinned rook
captures an e3 as a possibility and
definitely the best continuation for
white would be castling queenside
allowing rook captures on e3 and then
seek after some b7 Bishop captures on b7
queen capture some b7 and after a move
like rook to e8 Tom would have two rooks
in the attack this bishop on g7 is
pretty much ready to be activated on
that B to pawn through the Knights
the queen is also ready to jump into the
attack but with correct play white
shouldn't really have any problems here
but unfortunately for the Polish player
after this rook to e8 move he decided
not to cast Queen said and he played
King to f2 getting the King out of the
pin and also protecting the bishop on e3
and this was enough for tau to
immediately had to immediately start
pillaging rook captures on e3 and again
here white has plenty of options
his Knight is still under attack he can
capture the pawn on b7 of course he can
capture the rook with the King bringing
his King into e3 and I mean why not this
probably is the best move but it
requires a lot of calculation and this
is something you don't want to go into
against a guy like tall
for example King captures rook and then
Knight the g4 has to be considered and
thoroughly calculated unfortunately if
you capture the night you get Queen
captures on d4 now with the check
because after Knight to g4 check you
opened up this bishops attacked the d4
pawn and after King to e2 Bishop
captures on g4 might seem like like a
beast move but there's an even better
move Bishop to h6 and now with ideas of
Queen to d2 and Queen to e3 Bishop to g4
is always here you don't have to rush it
white would have to play something like
Queen to c2 and after a move like Bishop
to f5 getting the bishop into into the
game with tempo but what you're actually
doing is you're
making room for this rook the jump to e8
immediately and white doesn't have a
response here capturing the bishops
loses immediately to rook to e8 you
don't have a square for a king you have
to block it you lose the Queen and no
water moves are really even better I
mean you have to play something like
King to e1 to allow Bishop to e2 but
then you just lose the Queen and c2 so
this is completely completely terrible
for white
so after this King captures on e3 if you
do accept the rook after Knight to g4
you can't really capture the night you
have to play King to e2 and then well
where is this game going for white this
is something why I decided not to go
forth so after rook to e3 he played rook
to d1 now protecting his knight on d4
and also maybe threatening sea capture
some b7 but tal now immediately jumps
right back into the attack night that
the g4 would check now protecting the
rook on e3 white captured the night we
have Bishop captures on d4 now
threatening some very nasty discoveries
like rook captures night and c3 winning
the Queen or or any other discovery will
be deadly rook captures on d4 and Queen
capture some d4 now still threatening
all sorts of deadly discoveries Queen to
d5 white wants to exchange Queens now as
if the rook moves while white will just
grab the Queen and everything is
everything is perfect I mean why this up
a pawn but there is a one move that
white failed to take into consideration
rook to e2 with a double check and well
okay this is giving up a rook but this
is completely winning for tau King
captures any two pretty much only move
Bishop captures and g4 only now that
does the bishop come into the game with
tempo King has to go to e1 and now this
rook is free to jump to v8 rook to e8
with Czech Bishop to e2 and now I'm sure
you all see it rook captures an e2 and
in this position the Polish player
resign
the game it doesn't matter what it plays
there are two options if you play King
to f1 Queen to f2 is checkmate and if
you decide to capture the rook then the
knight is overloaded he cannot protect
the Queen anymore Knight captures rook
and then simply quick after screen white
doesn't have anything to hope for here
so I have two row captures any two white
resigned the game and yet yet another
brilliant victory for the pirate of riga
and yet yet another masterpiece for us
to admire so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and I will do I will do
another towel games since toss games are
so great I mean they're the best yeah I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank our army database for a
contribution to my channel think a lot I
really appreciate it as usual as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and for this video today special I will
put a link with all of the tile videos I
did in a playlist in the description
below so you can check out some of my
previous uploads if you if you haven't
seen them yet so yeah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon